USE ENERGY AS A WEAPON AND
BLACKMAIL, TO BLACKMAIL THE
WORLD.
CNN'S SAM KILEY HAS MORE ON
UKRAINIAN FORCES BATTLING TO
RETAKE TERRITORY EAST OF KYIV.
>> Reporter: RUSSIAN ARMOR
SMASHED IN A UKRAINIAN ASSAULT
EAST OF THE CAPITAL.
UKRAINE NOW CLAIMS TO HAVE
BLOCKED RUSSIA'S OFFENSIVE
AGAINST KYIV.
HE SAID, WE'VE BEEN ENGAGED IN A
COUNTERATTACK TO RECAPTURE IT.
THE OPERATION HAS BEEN A
COMPLETE SUCCESS.
WE DECIDEDLY REPELLED THE ENEMY.
AT TIME, IT'S BEEN A FEROCIOUS
INFANTRY FIGHT AND TAKEN SEVERAL
WEEKS.
UKRAINE HAS ALSO RELIED HEAVILY
ON MODERN DRONES, HERE AMBUSHES
FORCES FROM THE AIR.
TANK CREWS HAVE SENT RUNNING TO
COVER.
UKRAINE HAS CLAIMED THAT BADLY
LED RUSSIAN FORCES DO HAVE MORE
MANPOWER, BUT THEY'RE REELING
FROM UNEXPECTED ATTACKS AND
FLIES.
WHAT THEY SAY MAY BE TRUE,
ATTENDING TO THIS WOMAN TENDING
TO HER HUSBAND IN A NEARBY
HOSPITAL.
HER VILLAGE WAS OVERRUN BY
RUSSIANS.
SHE DESCRIBED DEALED WITH
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS WHO WERE HUNGRY
AND COLD AND OUT OF CONTROL.
SHE SAID THEY WORE MY WOMEN'S
HAT, MY HAT, MY BOOTS.
OUR CLOTHES.
MY CLOTHING.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'VE DONE
WITH IT.
THEY SLEPT, THEY ATE, THEY
WANDERED ABOUT.
THEY STOLE OUR MONEY.
A RUSSIAN SOLDIER WHO SHE SAID
WAS DRUNK BLASTED HER HUSBAND'S
LEG OFF WITH A STOLEN SHOTGUN.
THEN WE WERE TWO DAYS IN THE
BASEMENT.
WE STARTED STOPPING THE BLOOD
FLOW AND WE GOT TWO MEDICS, I'M
A MIDWIVE AND THERE WAS A NURSE
WITH HER.
TWO OFFICERS LATER ADMITTED THEY
DIDN'T SUPPORT PUTIN'S INVASION
AND OTHERS HELPED EVACUATE HER
HUSBAND TO UKRAINIAN LINES.
THIS MAN, A UKRAINIAN SOLDIER
WAS SHOT IN THE SHIN A FEW MILES
FROM THE HOSPITAL.
SHE SHARED HER EXTENT OF THE
RUSSIAN FORCES.
THESE BASTARDS ARE SENT TO THEIR
DEATHS.
THEY DON'T EVEN COUNT THEIR
LOSSES.
CIVILIANS HERE DO.
ANDRE ARRIVED AT THE HOSPITAL
WHEN WE WERE THERE.
HE'D BEEN HELPING HIS BROTHER
DMYTRO, A BEEKEEPER ATTEND HIS
SHELVES WHEN RUSSIAN SHELLS FELL
A FEW HOURS EARLIER.
MORTALLY WOUNDED HE WAS DEAD ON
ARRIVAL.
HE LEAVES A WIFE AND THREE KIDS.
HE SAID THESE MEN, THEY AREN'T
EVEN ANIMALS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO CALL THEM.
SAM KILEY.
CNN.
>>> RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR
PUTIN HAS ACCUSED RUSSIAN
NATIONS OF TRYING TO CANCEL
RUSSIAN CULTURE.
IN A TELEVISED MEETING MR. PUTIN
CLAIMED THAT RUSSIAN CULTURAL
EVENTS AROUND THE WORLD HAD BEEN
CANCELLED IN THE WEEKS.
AND CALLED SUFFICIENT ACTIONS.
>> Translator: THE CANCEL
CULTURE HAS TURNED INTO A CANCEL
CULTURE.
TCHAIKOVSKY IS EXCLUDED.
AND THE MASTERFUL CAMPAIGN FOR
FAVORABLE LITERATURE WAS CARRIED
OUT BY THE NAZIS AND GERMANS
YEARS AGO.
>> AND PUTIN ALSO COMPARED THE
TREATMENT OF RUSSIAN CULTURE TO
THE BACKLASH OVER HARRY POTTER
OVER HER OPINIONS ON TRANSGENDER
ISSUES.
>> CHILDREN'S BOOK WRITER J.K.
ROWLING WAS RECENTLY CANCELLED
BECAUSE HER BOOKS COPIED DID NOT
PLEASE THE FANS OF THE SO-CALLED
GENDER FREEDOM.
TODAY, THEY'RE TRYING TO CANCEL
THE COUNTRY, OUR PEOPLE, AND
TALKING ABOUT THE INCREASING
DISCRIMINATION OF EVERYTHING
RELATED TO RUSSIA, ABOUT THIS
TREND WHICH IS UNFOLDING IN A
NUMBER OF WESTERN STATES.
>> WELL, FOR HER PART, ROWLING
PUSHED BACK AGAINST BEING
BROUGHT INTO THE DISCUSSION.
TWEETING, QUOTE, CRITIQUES OF
WESTERN CANCEL CULTURE ARE
POSSIBLY NOT BEST MADE BY THOSE
CURRENTLY SLAUGHTERING CIVILIANS
FOR THE CRIME OF RESISTANCE OR
WHO ARE JAIL AND POISON THEIR
CRITICS.
>>> A TOP RUSSIAN GENERAL CLAIMS
THAT THE FIRST STAGE OF THE
INVASION IS COMPLETE.
AND ITS EFFORTS WILL NOW FOCUS
ON EASTERN UKRAINE.
JOURNALIST ATIKA SHUBERT IS
FOLLOWING THIS.
AND FOLLOWING THIS FROM UKRAINE.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US, ATIKA.
WHAT ARE WE PUTTING DOWN WITH
THIS CHANGE IN NARRATIVE THAT
WE'RE SEEING FROM THE ADVANCE
FROM RUSSIA?
>> WELL, IT IS DEFINITELY AND
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC MESSAGING
SHIFT.
AND IT'S DELIVERED BY COLONEL
GENERAL SERGEI RUDSKOY.
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT VOICE.
BY SAYING THAT THE MAIN GOALS,
THE LIBERATION OF DONBAS, THOSE
WERE HIS WORDS, THIS IS THE
DISPUTED EASTERN UKRAINE REGION
THAT HAS BEEN PARTIALLY
CONTROLLED BY RUSSIAN-BACKED
SEPARATISTS FOR YEARS NOW, SINCE
2014.
HE'S ALSO SIGNALING THAT THIS
HAS BEEN A MILITARY SUCCESS.
NOW, THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT WILL WE HEARD BEFORE,
CERTAINLY FROM RUSSIAN PRESIDENT
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HE PREVIOUSLY SAID THAT UKRAINE
SHOULDN'T EXIST AT ALL AS A
STATE.
AND SHOULD BE DEMILITARIZED AND
DENAZIIFIED.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT HE DENIES BY
THAT, IT'S FAILED TO CAPTURE
MAJOR CITIES, RECENTLY KYIV,
WHERE RUSSIAN TROOPS HAVE BEEN
BEATEN BACK RECENTLY.
AND IT'S HARD TO CALL THIS A
MILITARY SUCCESS IN ANY WAY,
ESPECIALLY WHEN BY RUSSIA'S OWN
ADMISSION YESTERDAY, MORE THAN
1,300 MILITARY PERSONNEL HAVE
DIED IN THE WAR SO FAR.
THE UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS PUT THAT
NUMBER MUCH, MUCH HIGHER.
AND NATO AND U.S. DEFENSE
OFFICIALS BELIEVE AT LEAST 7,000
RUSSIAN TROOPS HAVE BEEN KILLED.
INCLUDING SEVERAL HIGH-RANKING
COMMANDING OFFICERS.
WHY THEN DO WE SEE THIS
MESSAGING OF CHANGING THE GOALS
AND PAINTING THIS AS A
SUCCESSFUL MILITARY OPERATION.
I THINK THIS COULD BE A POSSIBLE
WAY TO FIND A FACE-SAVING
TENABLE POSITION AT THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE.
REMEMBER THAT UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY
HAS REPEATEDLY SAID, THE ONLY
WAY FORWARD, THE ONLY WAY TO
SOLVE THIS IS DIRECT TALKS WITH
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
SO WHAT WE COULD SEE NOW IS THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY SIGNALLING THAT
ITS CHANGING ITS GOALS, CHANGING
THE NARRATIVE, IN ORDER TO WALK
IT BACK TO THE NEGOTIATING
TABLE.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE'RE
GOING TO SEE LESS FIGHTING ON
THE GROUND.
IN FACT, WE COULD SEE AN
INTENSIFICATION, CERTAINLY
AROUND THE DISPUTED AREAS LI